This year, in the midst of
many challenges, we have been so grateful
for you, our community. You've continued
to show up in so many different ways,
even as the ways we work with
and live have changed.
You've used data to answer questions
important to you,
written insightful code, helped people learn,
and continued to share everything you do
with your communities,
coworkers, neighbors, family and friends.
Thank you for your kindness,
your curiosity, and bringing all of you
to the ways that you work with and share
about data. From RStudio Open Source,
thank you.
Thank you.
[GERMAN: Thank you very much.]
[FRENCH: Thank you.]
Thank you.
A big thank you to the entire open
source community. [TELUGU: Thank you.]
Thank you.
[TURKISH: Thank you.]
Hey, you're using the things we made, and
I really appreciate that. Thank you.
[FRENCH: Thank you.]
Thank you.
[MARA, VOICEOVER: You wanna say thank you?]
[MANDARIN: Thank you.]
[CANTONESE: Thank you.]
[JAPANESE: Thank you.]
Thank you.
Thank you
for all the ways you contribute and share.